sure and this fundamental idea that
sobriety is good yes no you look on
Instagram people post a selfie and say
six months sober guys thank you so much
and tons of congratulations because it's
a virtue because you accomplished
something you're not using drugs yeah
whereas in other cultures that would not
be the case people would just say oh
you've decided not to work with a
certain medicine that it's an
interesting choice not an accomplishment
now what was it saying was it kyle
Kingsbury that was saying that how much
he hates the term plant medicine or was
it Dennis thing was tile you don't like
the term plant medicine do I don't you
well do you bother there's a it's a
weird sort of pretentious yes yes I know
what people call ayahuasca the medicine
or things like that yeah or tows
medicine I mean I wouldn't you don't
hate it
I a lot of these like more flowery terms
like entheogen and I just don't use them
myself but I don't hate it
well you're you know I think people like
you were very important and I'm a big
fan but I think one of the reasons why
you're important is you are a
cognoscenti of real drugs like you you
understand what they actually do you
could explain them to the layman or you
could debate them with someone who was a
doctor perhaps that wanted to you know
to talk about the dangers of them and
you understand all the various aspects
of it and I think there's a tremendous
amount of ignorance when it comes to
drugs drug consumption what is a drug I
mean how many times have you seen a
person with a beer in their hand smoking
a cigarette saying they don't do drugs
it is so [ __ ] stupid but it's it's so
common there's this very very very
common aspect of being a person which is
these desire to change your mental state
and we've done it throughout history
with various substances but there's so
much stigma attached to it and one of
the things I've been doing lately on
stage I'll ask people how many people
get pissed tested at work it's [ __ ]
stunning it's stunning it's like more
than 10% of the audience will raise the
hand like one out of ten people gets
there their body tested to make sure
that while they're not working there
they're not putting anything in their
body
it's prohibited which is such a horrible
invasion of privacy they you know that
became so popular that in the 80s or in
one presidential election all the
candidates voluntarily had their urine
tested to prove that they were sober I
mean this is like truly considered a
virtue and it's immensely invasive I say
this is someone who's analyzed my own
urine in a laboratory before and it's
like a strange portal into your own life
they're showing to a stranger everything
that you've consumed is then apparent
there yeah and it's incredibly it's a
huge invasion of privacy that we've just
decided is acceptable you have to be
very careful about these things yeah no
I agree it's and of course the synthetic
cannabinoid epidemic if you want to call
it that I actually don't want to call it
that because even the idea of a drug
epidemic but the the popularity of
synthetic cannabinoids is largely driven
by the fact that they didn't show up on
these urine tests so initially was in
the military then it was people who are
on parole or probation people who were
living hard lives wanted to get high
couldn't get high this was a way that
they could do it and so they've
incentivized people that just wanted to
smoke weed using completely untested
synthetic cannabinoids instead as a
direct result of these urine tests well
it's also just a complete
misunderstanding it comes to the actual
effects and how long they last you're
not even testing a person's conscious
state you're testing whether or not a
person has altered their state of
consciousness outside of their their
working time you know it's not like you
show up and they could scan your hand
and realize that you're high on
marijuana right now it's not what
they're doing what they're doing is
they're they're testing you for
something that could linger in your body
for weeks after these psychoactive
effects of long since gone oh yeah or
even be the result of passive exposure
there was a great scientific article
that came out a couple of years ago
where they found that just passive
exposure to cannabis smoke contaminates
her hair with THC so that all these
people who had hair tests who actually
had not smoked cannabis but it sounds
like an excuse I was just in the room
someone else is doing it just being in
contact with someone who'd smoked
cannabis could then deposit THC in your
hair and cause you to test
so these tests aren't even necessarily
reliable this is the same problem there
is a kind of trend a little while ago if
you saw about this where people would
get their urine tested for different to
quantify the levels of neurotransmitter
metabolites in their urine and this was
supposed to be like a fingerprint of
your mood so they'd quantify the level
of serotonin dopamine GABA whatever
whatever whatever and then they'd say oh
you're a little low on serotonin you're
pretty depressed actually you need to
supplement with some 5-htp or something
like that it's a very reductive way of
thinking about consciousness but the
main issue is that you're not testing in
your brain you're testing your urine and
a lot of these neurotransmitters are bio
synthesized in the periphery so just
because you have these neurotransmitters
in your urine doesn't mean they were
ever in your brain it doesn't say
anything about anything so it's just
it's so juvenile in a way it says such a
it's such a piss-poor way of maintaining
order
checking people's consciousness and make
it me what you should do is judge people
based on the productivity if I have some
guy and he shows up work and he kicks
ass every day I'm like dude what's your
secret you know I get high before work
it's great
I feel good having a good time at work
Zippity doo da Zippity de I'm putting
everything in order and it just feels
good like keep doing what you're doing